blowing the whistle is no longer a
courageous Act of saving democracy
according to the Democrats Nancy Pelosi
blasting Republicans for holding a
hearing featuring two IRS agents who
claim Hunter Biden got special treatment
in his tax case
what a ridiculous
clown show again on the part of the
Republicans but I have respect for
whistleblowers but the fact is that from
the basis of that hearing there they
didn't even have a fair shot at what
they came to say in light of the clown
show that was going on with pictures and
I'm not confident about what the
Whistleblower said the U.S attorney the
Trump attorney this is their opinion it
was not the opinion of others there the
media backing up Nancy's attacks on the
GOP
if you thought a hearing with two IRS
whistleblowers was going to be tame
you'd be wrong this is the reality of
the Republican investigation into the
so-called Biden crime family it's
seemingly riddled with stunts and
conspiracies if this is all sounding
like deja vu that's because these
allegations have already been
investigated over and over and over
again but it looks like Republicans
aren't going to stop the GOP is gearing
up to hear from Hunter's ex-partner
Devon Archer Devin
okay and a new report in the New York
Post revealing that he plans to tell
them that Hunter put his father the then
VP on the phone with business associates
at least two dozen times two dozen times
Jesse let me do the math for you that's
over 24. you're right about that I I
mean that's that's amazing do you talk
to your dad 24 times I haven't talked to
him 24 times in a year yes that's what I
mean but Joe and his dad talk every
single day yes so a couple things they
said that remember when Hunter was on
the phone and he threatened the Chinese
to pay up because his dad was right next
to him turns out
Hunter was driving his dad's Corvette
around Delaware that same day so that
puts Joe and Hunter at the same location
plus the FBI if they wanted to they
could pinpoint his location the FBI
could also tell us what was in Patrick
hoe's laptop and phone remember Hunter
was paid a million dollars by the
Chinese to represent the Chinese spy
that got clipped at JFK the FBI seized
his laptop and his phones and then used
it in the court case so what are they
hiding they knew what hoe was telling
the chairman about Joe and Hunter and
then all of a sudden Hunter's took over
in the Middle East at the Four Seasons
uh yeah let me call my dad I'm going to
put him on speaker yeah these are the
barisma guys that Joe Biden has claimed
that he never ever talked to now we have
like six people seven people that say
they talk all the time what does it tell
you when President Joe Biden is trying
to put his opponent in prison and then
trying to keep his own son out of prison
last time I checked the Democrats love
whistleblowers they wanted to give them
all guns double the their Workforce they
were hoping that every IRS agent could
lock up all of these rich white guys
cheating on their taxes then all of a
sudden an IRS whistleblower second one
was a gay Democrat IRS whistleblower
found some rich white guys cheating on
their taxes now it's a clown show give
me a break every time they tried to
serve a search warrant they got tipped
off every time they tried to pursue a
lead to the big guy they got obstructed
it's called obstruction of justice it's
called corruption compare that to Trump
man the guy was an open book and his
whole family set it for depositions he
handed over thousands of documents he
had to answer for two years about a
crime that never even existed Joe hasn't
had to answer once about this Hey Joe
did you ever meet Tony B Hey Joe did you
ever talk to the ukrainians guys because
they say they have you on tape answer
some questions answer one question he
couldn't last five minutes not with me
no with Brett Bear no
yeah Dana well I think the left's entire
strategy here is to kick up a lot of
dust around it to confuse people and
part of that could be working right
however the problem for them is that the
facts in this continued to get worse and
worse the I don't know if you saw it but
in the briefing today Karen Jean-Pierre
had a little slight change of phrasing
okay she said President Biden was never
in business with his son
for months she has referred all of those
questions to the White House counsel's
Office in which they say like he's
already spoken on this and Biden
maintains he never asked his son
anything about his business dealings
however now you have all of these people
what are the chances that all of these
different entities are all lying about
the very same thing even if they're not
related to each other and they're all
doing it under oath under penalty of
having to go to jail for it I think that
that is why the White House is probably
even more concerned The credibility of
The Whistleblower unfortunately is in
the eye of the beholder of course and
it's unfortunate because a lot of people
that I worked with in the government the
bureaucrats they're really good people
they work hard they care about what they
do what I don't understand is why the
bureaucracy always votes for the
Democratic party in large measure like
like 80 or something like that because
look how quickly somebody like Nancy
Pelosi will turn on you
what do you think Jessica why is that
the case
what are you trying to hide Jesse let me
see that
thanks answer your question while I
think about this thank you all you think
about the girls in the Corvette yes this
is troubling what are they trying to
hide I did I did think that
Nancy Pelosi was drawing a distinction
between the whistleblowers themselves
being a clown show and the Republican
line of questioning and you have to look
no further than Marjorie Taylor green
whipping out a picture of Hunter Biden's
penis to say oh this is a little bit of
a clown show right this is deteriorating
can you find a picture of him without
his penis
what are you gonna do
I believe I tried I mean she use the
word whipped it out I thought it was
good for emphasis no I say Liberals are
no fun
um I didn't think that the
whistleblowers seemed not credible I
thought that their answers seemed
completely credible but just didn't
support the GOP narrative about it like
Gary shapley for instance under
questioning from rokana he said you know
on average how many times did you refer
someone to the tax Council as the ones
who decide who's going to get prosecuted
and they uh didn't take your advice and
he said the vast majority of times or
Joseph Ziegler your our gay Democrat
whistleblower talking about how he would
ask the higher-ups and say you know I
want to move forward I want to ask
questions about this and they would say
it's just it's too much we're not gonna
be able to do that and they were the
Trump appointees that were telling him
that it wasn't Garland sitting there it
was a David Weiss saying it A.G Barr so
the narrative just completely falls
apart were you saying the U.S government
blocks Prosecuting tax cheats all the
time
yeah
really that's your argument that people
don't get away all the time with
cheating on their taxes
guilty wait a second Jessica if I don't
carry the one I go to prison on my taxes
really you'd be in jail
middle class people that waitresses get
audited you're saying they're like oh
you know forget about it what's a
million well whatever I use the Roger
the Roger Stone example then contrary to
Jessica said that The Narrative of
falling apart you don't know what I'm
talking about I never asked we're here
look contrary to Jessica's saying that
the narrative is falling apart it's
actually being corroborated by different
places so first of all you have the
whistleblowers for the most recent you
have the FBI 1023 which mentions Joe
Biden as the big guy and bribery and
being mentioned that Hunter will use him
to get verisma into United States in the
initial public offering changing foreign
policy you had Tony bobolinski who was
Hunter Biden's business partner during
the 2020 election who was blowing the
whistle on all of this in the media they
ignored and buried the story you have
Devin Archer testifying on Monday that
this was going on and the Obama White
House was asked about this in the
briefing room repeatedly about Hunter
Biden's position on the Prisma board and
whether it was a problem because the
state department at the time was
investigating Prisma for corruption and
there was a massive conflict of interest
lo and behold we have whistleblower
information now that Joe Biden was
involved during that exact time looks
like that perfect phone call yeah it was
a perfect phone I was just going to
bring up the phone call I reread the
phone call to refresh my memory I always
said that and if you look at the way
that they did the impeachment process
Democrats loved whistleblowers right but
actually look at the transcript zlenski
is offering for paragraphs of
conversations cooperation because he was
new in the position as president he
wanted to work with Trump so Trump takes
him up on the offer and says hey why
don't you look into this fight in
corruption which was real and then they
impeached him for it oh my God there you
go look into my political opponent or I
won't give you your weapons isn't it
it's much better to arrest your
political opponent we do what we can all
right you do excellent whipping out hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now